when you did that i was in
budapest doing a movie because that's
the reason why i couldn't do that one
and what was the name of that movie it's
called borderlands it's not out yet
borderline yeah borderlands borderline
it's based on a video it's big yeah but
you know with cape blanchetts and that's
why oh my god budget they blanch it okay
you win but this is not what is that
what winning is this it's always about
winning
you just won yeah yeah well it was like
a hard decision because it was like
because joe you know i knew him when he
was a kid
like i knew him we were both open micros
together and he had his hair he had hair
i met him when he was working behind the
front desk of a motel in vegas that's
when i knew him too and he had his
glasses and his hair yeah he said i said
oh
checking in late tia carrera me and my
mom were checking in at this
alexia place he reminded me of the name
and uh he said oh your tia career i know
you you're a filipina actress i want to
be a comic but my mom wants me to be a
nurse yeah so it's like it's true you
know the all the surgery you remember
that
i did not
then no but then he reminded me because
he was opening for lovetts at the laugh
factory yeah and i said oh my god you're
hilarious because he came off you're
filipino you're so good and he goes we
met before and i said
wait and he said the motel i was oh my
god all of a sudden i just remembered
clearly but he just had to say that you
know behind the front desk of the motel
i was like i remember clearly i spent i
don't know 20 minutes at the front desk
saying hey you know you got to do it if
you love it and you can't imagine your
life without trying this thing you know
you're going to regret it the rest of
your life
you know so
funny huh yeah even back then though you
could see
something like he
so dynamic on stage great impression
like impressions great singing and like
an entertainer even as an open micro wow
right like it wasn't like nothing was
there like in terms of like joke
structure or a set
right but he would just bust into
michael jackson or do whatever he and
you could just kind of go oh this guy is
so confident and it's also like you know
we're both asian kids
in the 90s when no one else was around
and it was just an odd not odd but it
was like i i honestly think that
i don't believe i mean i kind of believe
in god but i believe that
destiny kind of made us meet you know i
mean in la jolla that one night where we
could become friends you know i mean
because without him doing it i don't
know what my motivation because it's it
was such a white and black
dominated
things confirmed what you felt in
yourself that you could do it and here's
somebody else doing it so let's be yeah
it was really kind of and you know thank
god for the mexicans too because because
back then
yeah well the mexicans too i mean they
really rallied behind both yeah the
mexicans rallied behind me you know i
mean but without the mexicans and guys
like joe coy
i don't know if i'd still be here doing
it you know i mean because it was just
like i needed a clan you need a tribe
right who are you hanging out with back
in the 80s
i i you know i have i have sisters my
family's always been very important yeah
uh and they're you know the grounding
factor in my life because
i feel like i'm part of the circus
troupe that like you know you're part of
a show and you become this intimate
dysfunctional family and then it ends
and then you move on to the next troupe
of people and you become you know tight
as thieves and then that so this that
constantly messes with your head because
you're embedding with different troops
all along the way